[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of rick and morty season four
episode
updates justin roiland went on the h3 h3
podcast last december he explained where
they're at he talked about the episode
count and talked about the number of
animatics that they're ready to ship off
which actually gives us a pretty good
idea of the schedule that they're on and
when they'll be able to air episodes so
we'll break it all down what I'll do is
I'll play the clip of him talking about
it then I'll talk about all the things
that they've said so far about what's
gonna be different during season four
from previous seasons if you're just
finding my channel for the first time I
do Rick and Morty episodes for every
season be sure to subscribe to get
everything
here's the clip of Justin roiland
talking about season 4 episodes so Rick
and Morty huge Rick and Morty news the
show was renewed big-time yeah tell me
about that so we got we got a we got a
big hefty order for more episodes oh
tell me about how big was the order it
was like another six season right it's
it's it was it's 70 episodes 70 and
we're in the middle of production on
this oh god I mean well the jury's out
on that one I mean hopefully not
hopefully not you know a long amount of
time now you guys are currently in
production of the new season right yeah
and how is that going it's great it's
going good we've got we've got really
good we've got some really good stuff
well you have episodes in the can we
have we have some animatics in the can
yeah like we I mean we're shipping stuff
is getting shipped or about to be
episodes are about to be shipped for
color animation but yeah like we're
we're we're moving along Ethan and
you're and got a good season that's
great yeah everyone's gonna be cool the
important thing that he says during that
is the number of animatics that they're
getting ready to ship off remember this
was recorded back in the middle of
december so has actually been a long
time they've already shipped those
animatics that he was talking about
usually when they ship an animatic off
it takes them about six weeks to animate
the episode then once they get the
finished product back they'll tune some
of the dialogue maybe change some of the
jokes out then the episode is done so
they're actually a little bit ahead
of schedule from where they were at this
point during season three remember they
had the episode done by the time I got
to April Fool's that's why they did that
special April Fool's Day episode because
because they had it sitting there and
ready to go and it been so long since
the previous season because for a year I
had been suffering a lot of kids
tweeting me going like where's the
where's the new episode where's the
where's the new season and not being
able to say anything I I did get did
give me license for what I got I got to
pick one kid waited like five minutes
before the premiere and he tweeted me
and said come on where's the season and
I responded to him going like what do
you want me to do wave a magic wand and
just make the premiere of Rick and Marty
happen just because you asked and
knowing that he'd go yeah I do they're
like all right you get this one turn on
your TV and I have a feeling that kid's
gonna grow up to be either president or
a serial killer so because they changed
their promotional tactics between
seasons I'm not expecting them to do the
exact same thing for season four but as
it stands right now they're on track to
air episodes during the summer now they
could choose to move that up a little
bit if the episodes are done a little
bit sooner because the last couple of
seasons they've started in July so very
conservative estimate just plan on to
july premiere if it happens before then
then we'll just all celebrate and go
crazy but remember they didn't drop the
first official season 3 trailer until
the beginning of the summer so with the
exception of maybe like a spring stunt
if they want to promote things just to
remind people hey we're back after that
long break i'm not really expecting to
see a lot of finished animation or
trailers or promos or anything like that
to the beginning of the summer so it's
still gonna be a little while but
they've been posting from the writers
room justin roiland and dan harmon have
been posting from the voice-over booth
justin roiland
actually just teased that they're doing
interdimensional cable 3 which if you
remember they were originally planning
on doing when they were still gonna do
14 episodes during season 3 but then
behind the scenes there was some problem
that they didn't really explain they had
to cut the episode order down to 10 so
they decided to do more teas mind
blowers in place of another
interdimensional cable which is why they
had the joke at the beginning of the
episode I never
for this to be a substitute for inner
German of us did we we had this all
planned out this was gonna air this was
gonna air ninth and then and then the
actual interdimensional cable three was
gonna air twelfth in a world where we
had fourteen and then we would have done
we've done you know two more and I would
have been that but yeah we we had we had
we had due to numerous production snafus
we had that we had that we had to cut
his upset as everyone was about not
getting another interdimensional cable
episode I feel like Morty's mine blowers
was such a cool episode that hopefully
they'll do that again at some point
maybe not right away during season four
but maybe again during season five when
Justin roiland was talking about the
episodes he didn't specify whether they
were planning on airing ten episodes per
season or fourteen episodes because
those 70 episodes work out to either
five years of 14 episodes per season or
seven years of 10 episodes per season if
you watch any of Cartoon Network's other
animated series like Steven universe or
Adventure Time you know that sometimes
they air weird blocks of episodes that
don't totally make sense the schedule is
really hard to follow the upside I think
is is that Rick and Morty is a little
more serialized and it's more of an
adult audience so they're more willing
to air it in just straight blocks of 10
episodes or 14 episodes or whatever is
going to be going forward the other big
things that they've said about season
four and how things are going to be
different from season three are mostly
talking about the dynamic inside the
house the dynamic outside the house like
internal threats to the family and
external threats so Dan Harmon was
really clear in that season four is
gonna basically take things back to more
of a season one season two type of
dynamic where the family is largely
localized to the house they won't be
focusing a lot on the will they won't
they get a divorce of beth and jerry's
marriage jerry is still gonna be the
punching bag but the big dynamic change
is that rick is no longer the power of
the family he's sort of relegated to
status that he had during season one
season two they didn't take all of his
power away or anything like that but
they did force him to verbally
acknowledge that there wasn't anything
that he was going to be able to do about
this that's why he said I surrender
Jerry fine you win you get my family
so even though he's super pissed it just
means that he won't be constantly trying
to get rid of Jerry at every turn every
single episode that means relatively
stable family unit for the duration of
the season like it was during season one
implying that the house itself will be a
much more central location than it was
during season 3 just because you have
Jerry's apartment and at various points
everybody was off in different
directions they sort of brought things
full circle with Morty and summer so
their relationship with Rick is a little
bit like it was during season 1 season 2
but it's not like they're suddenly gonna
forget everything that they've been
through so like Morty has effectively
done a lap on the Rick's circuit like he
went from idealizing him and
simultaneously being terrified of him
during season 1 asserting himself to
Rick during season 2 then to the
beginning of season 3 where he flat-out
rejected Rick and did everything he
could to try and get summer to stop
believing in him in summer sort of
started on her own little version of the
Morty arc where she's like this is so
awesome I'm so happy to be going out on
adventures with Rick then by the end of
the season morty chilled out on rick a
little bit realized how important he was
to the family emotionally and literally
how much they needed him to protect them
from external threats like evil Morty
the Citadel of Rick's if the government
ever became a really big thing Rick is
very much a necessary evil that was kind
of the relationship between him and the
president at the end with fishing Rick
like hey I'm a totally different Rick
we're just gonna pretend like this is a
thing so we can go back to our normal
relationship they clear by this moment
later in the commentary where Keith
David's president is pretty sure that
this is the same version of Rick but he
knows how much he needs Rick and Rick
can't leave the planet because he needs
his family even though he hates to admit
it so they're perpetuating this lie in
the name of taking things back to the
way they used to be which is kind of
where Rick is with the family at the end
of the season where they've been through
all this crazy stuff but Beth and Jerry
decided they're gonna make a go of their
marriage Morty and some are just happy
to have the family back together and
even though Rick is really pissed off
about it he's forced to accept it
effectively taking a lot of the power
away from him that he gained within the
family during season 3 which is why Dan
Harmon Justin roiland talked about it
going back to more of a season 1 season
2 dynamic the upside now though is that
you have a season for Morty that's way
less uptight but makes more informed
choices some are also doing kind of the
same thing while she goes on adventures
with Rick and now that Beth has been
canonized as being almost as intelligent
as Rick she also gets to be in on the
fun too even though there's
sort of the hanging plot thread of
whether or not it's the fake version of
Beth that Rick offered her like just go
out and have fun traveling the
multiverse we'll put a duplicate in your
place they won't know the difference
even if this is the real version of Beth
I still think they're gonna have fun
with the idea that she's almost as smart
as Rick and will thus be able to
participate in some of the shenanigans
that he gets into during the season
so because the divorce isn't a big thing
they're not that many internal threats
to the family but external you have
stuff like The Citadel of Rick's
rebuilding itself under evil Morty's
banner that's always gonna be a
long-term threat to c-137 brick and even
though he did destroy the Galactic
government in Episode one there's still
all that infrastructure left for someone
to see someone like Tammy in Phoenix
person Phoenix person is a really good
character if they want to bring him back
to tug a trick in an emotional way
because right now you know like he just
hates Tammy and probably wants to kill
her but you bring Phoenix person back
and that completely complicates the
matter because then you have this whole
Robocop idea with his character where
maybe he can remember all the memories
from before his accident before Tammy
turned him into the cyborg so let me
know in the comments beyond what they've
already confirmed what do you want them
to bring back or do during season four
and remember there's 70 episodes so if
they don't get to stuff during season
four they'll probably get to it in
season five season 6 season 7 what'll
happen is is I'll do more regular Rick
and Morty bonus videos as we get closer
to the season premiering they usually
don't tell you when that's gonna happen
until it gets real close but what'll
probably happen is it just like for
season 3 we'll start seeing some
animatics and some early teasers so
leave all your Rick and Morty bonus
video requests in the comments below
but click here for that Rick and Morty
season 4 teaser trailer and click here
for all my Rick and Morty season 3
Easter egg videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]